[Music]
in the state still News Fox a to that
Bush [ __ ] everybody freeze
now that mean Clement submitted by not
naked
Brandon not negative close it too close
Landon it's not Brandon miss Blanton
land in any cake AED mechanic gauges
because of the way justices that's a
like a mega Brandon you know why it's
because he's like my former roommate and
he was always shirtless and all the
girls Drew's hahahaha they say Oh naked
Brandi yeah and I was like okay let me
give you some more [ __ ] prepubescent
girls from porn whatever gets the views
so cool any talk or dude warned my
stomach just didn't do it for them but
Brandon on the other hand whoo he made
all those patties moist I am a
prepubescent and moist pennies it
happened
don't you remember being on attitude
it's like look at in sigue get [ __ ]
hell the horchata time dude I saw this
one video I was I swear to God I was
like what the [ __ ] but just go ahead a
picture of Justin Bieber as a poster and
she was like in backing it up on his ass
and I was like damn - seems like Tok fun
I found his creature 12 year old girl on
Facebook it she was like doing one of
these and a [ __ ] ten year old boy was
like I stick my dick so deep in there
and that asked King Arthur will have to
pull it out what a clever eyes oh my god
yeah these kids are [ __ ] funny
Instagram no those are mean oh what the
pictures at Facebook conversations now I
thought you were like on these
prepubescent I do
I know genius a 45 year old man had been
working as a statue for 32 years
oh that's me Francisco or something have
you seen those guys like a street
performer yeah they can oh those guys
scare me
I make their own sounds I saw pretty
good they're pretty good hour to be
right now yeah that's mine at the
college war don't act like that wasn't
good that's pretty good now you got
moves Mike right I would hire you in my
crew music video yeah start up like a
robot I thought you loved doing 2017
Cheers
here's no sense of year is this empty no
what's happening yeah a lots happened I
need you a timeline what's going on okay
yeah so this 54 year-old man has been
working as a statue for 32 years
why are you dedicated well I wonder if
that was his passion one day I would be
a statue be the best statue I would be
the most frozen mother but the ice cubes
would be so jealous of me so this man's
name is Abdul Aziz and he first started
working as a security guard at this a
place called VGP Golden Beach Resort in
Chennai in India so it's a beach resort
and so he first started working there as
a security guard his boss traveled to
London and saw like the booking him
palace guards are like this right yeah
and so he loved it so much that when he
went back home he started pretty much
auditioning all the security guards to
see if they can stand there without
moving or like reacting to anything and
so Abdul surpass everyone he not happens
when something goes down though then
they're allowed to move law like what's
the limit I know
so this man he can't move at all or even
he wasn't even blink - something bad
real here rape rapes happening and he's
just well that's what I'm paid to do no
yeah so there are other guards around
him he's not allowed to so he can't move
but there are other grapes happening
right here you're these other Guerra
these rape is happening yeah what do you
do my boss told me to stay ha ha you
just said that
well yeah so I was the most useless
security guard what do I pay you to do
just that I he's not security guard
anymore he the statue
yeah so legally just gave up as human
capable against human card oh I see so
he does this we're during his shift was
about which is about 6 hours windows II
[ __ ]
when did they eat he I don't know
he doesn't does he want a diaper 6 hours
I guess you could go no poop 6 now know
about you does say that when he's not
working he tries to move as much as we
can because doing this job for so many
years standing still for such a long
time it's been taking a toll on his body
in circulation he's starting to have
like issues we do drugs god no I don't
know like a DD like I couldn't do that
he's just doing aerobics all day long
well when he's not working and he says
when he tries to eat as healthy as
possible and like home-cooked meals he
tries to keep his body in shape he he
claims that yoga has been his biggest
help so I like that's what it stands -
yeah you're saying that it maybe it's
the complete opposite no it's because
he's sitting in the back of the yoga
class and all you see is the ass
so he's like heshes making me feel alive
again
all the I could ever be a statute that's
just too crazy he was like oh yeah yeah
every day so good and when he does that
I put his [ __ ] on his hand that his boss
even offered a reward to anyone I can
make him flinch a react or worst boss in
the world I'm down the hell
no lines on this date has has gotten
back where you can poke his eyeball no
way you can't touch them oh no their art
so like I said before there are other
guards around him to make sure like you
know people don't [ __ ] with him too much
but because on them also his boss just
got him just for entertainment yes
because he loved the booking impellers
all kind of boss yeah it's a holiday
longer than actually what don't know
what it is she's the boss of a security
thing you know I don't I don't think it
was only on how heavy is that thing
that's the resource six hours [ __ ]
that's that's hard that looks like a
Indian Palace dude he's the easiest
person to photograph though that's not
that's not a best that you a lot of
tourists have been going there for him
yeah statues wonder like a nut tap I
feel like if he's a real dude it's not
you know but if you're within 3 feet on
mine
at least you do one of those you know
now you said that he's seen it all like
people I've tried to do everything try
to get them to react like girls probably
banning overriding oh yeah yeah a little
up yeah I think we do that in Atlanta
move common didn't his next move good
keep move don't you go but you Nexus
yeah he's been doing it since 1985 have
you guys seen those videos of the palace
guards at Buckingham Palace and like if
you get too close they [ __ ] jail
step away from the Queen's God really
yeah for real it's pretty crazy a
student beat someone that was yeah like
someone like hit him I like to mess with
them yeah I do like dropped his rifle
but on him or someone yeah don't think
dumb yeah and then put on the right
bottom yeah I'll do like monks headed
like sat there for years yeah heard this
much might be 107 River sometime of
Siddhartha no my mom those are my mom
Tommy yeah your mother is let's go for
longer six hours yeah my mom stood still
like meditates from a long last time
I've heard and this could be 100%
[ __ ] somebody told me that someone
like stood there with their hand up
forever and they did it so long their
hand started
oh it could be true there's a lot of
weird stories like that there's there's
just one guy that meditated and
petrified himself that's kind of like
this is chilled and basically just yeah
slowly like petrified himself and then
they put it they put him into like a
porcelain casing so that's kind of what
I'm thinking uh person destroyed that
like their blood just went away and then
their skin started to go away and they
started to disintegrate because they're
just sitting there meditating my mom
says she has this friend and I don't
alter the story is but this friend went
into the mountain to meditate and
because this person was so Zen my time
passes really quickly and I guess this
person since he was just going to
meditate for a little bit in this cave
he bought a bunch of potatoes and foil
and and so he just made a little
campfire and I put the potatoes in there
anyways okay cool after I'm done
meditating I'll be able to eat these
potatoes when he was done meditating he
opened the foil and all the potatoes
were moldy now apparently is been dead
by two months or something like that it
turned into the future yeah you meant to
it's like 2 months I don't know you
don't have people my mom like hang on
how I survived so easy the melancholy
I'm gonna lie to her so hard
look I got but I got special powers
don't tell anybody but I went to a cave
the other day and then I chilled in
there and I didn't breathe or anything
for like a whole week didn't eat and I
came back out I think I'm enlightened
she's gonna be so proud of me
yeah and I should agree you took that
she loves calling me fat that's how she
shows love yeah so he saw this human
statue he does have children and what
he's saying that you know he doesn't
want his kids upon and puts up because
it's too challenging
I'm sure that's what they really aspire
to be my god Dan well he is training
someone right now to take over to be
planning to retire take your kid to work
day when I had kids someone else you
know what maybe monks built date they're
jealous right now they're like six hours
you know how long it took me to get six
hours down Oh No and he gets paid I
don't even get paid for this Chester
yeah but it's craziness it's hours
straight through the booking impellers
cards they've changed shift after every
two hours oh that makes sense
six hours cause I was thinking if you're
just standing still for such a long time
your bodies are stiffing up right so
some [ __ ] actually happens in a pull
something the mini try to respond
looking a palace or whatever they're
like the actual guards - yeah yeah
they're military in there and ER the
[ __ ] person yeah but he's not an ass
walkabout
no he's decoration yeah the things you
got to do in India to earn a living oh
man
well you like the dude does though
really I've heard of horror stories
doing stunts out there dude it's crazy
pretty bad dude like though I heard
stories of like movie sets and they'll
like throw people off the moving trains
and [ __ ] and like they won't take them a
hospital they're like oh yeah he can
pretty much just die and like they'll
just keep going and [ __ ] like that yeah
just use it using and abuse and some
exercises China's crazy what's not as
crazy as China I'm sorry it's um it's
more crazy in India because if you come
on set food is your pay
but like no hospital there's no
insurance nothing like the most amount
of people right yeah they just find
another way right black just let us die
I've seen my friends like a story where
there's hundreds of people like yelling
and screaming on the gates like let them
in like they'll do stunts they want to
be in the movie extras we just want to
kneel so they're just starting yeah
keeps me pen down jaqen fries so like I
said I'll just still trash them out
there like and then get the next guy
it's crazy I hope you guys enjoyed this
video for more please subscribe to our
Channel and you can check out the last
video right here
[Music]
[Music]